from an automaker
to a coffee chain and major fashion
brands he is the one eighteen-year-old
eileen goo is the face of ad campaigns
for about 30 chinese and western
companies the u.s born freestyle skier
has become an overnight sensation
winning her first gold medal while
representing china at the beijing winter
olympics she's quite possibly the
biggest thing in sports the biggest
thing in the two biggest economies in
the world goo's ability to cast herself
as both chinese and american has been a
boon for companies but that could also
become tricky it's incredibly difficult
uh to to walk the fine line between
between the two sides yes there's always
going to be a risk because of the the
political situation we look at goo's
marketability to both the us and china
as companies try to balance the risks
and rewards that come with her dual
identity
[Music]
here's why goo checks many boxes for
consumers in both countries she's smart
and will be attending stanford
university
goo's not just a supermodel but also a
dominating force in her sport
i definitely feel as though i am just as
american as i am chinese she's also
fluent in english and mandarin which she
speaks with a beijinger's accent
there's no one else like her who's as
dominant in her sport who's truly
multinational and who has one foot
squarely in two countries
in the middle of the biggest event in
china's recent sports history
born in san francisco to an american
father and a chinese mother goo trained
to ski in the u.s but announced three
years ago that she'd be competing for
china so when goo won gold in the big
air skiing event at the winter games she
dominated trending topics on weibo the
country's version of twitter
the hashtag eileen goo gold medal was
viewed more than 1 billion times that
day
but a big part of her popularity is not
about what she's doing on the slopes she
is really um
you know strenuously apolitical the you
know there's nothing controversial about
about her brand and this tactic has been
key to her success goo's new york-based
agent declined to comment for this video
she's also stayed away from politically
charged topics like the us's diplomatic
boycott of the olympics over alleged
human rights abuses in xinjiang beijing
has defended its treatment of uighur
muslims there as an effort to combat
extremism when she's asked questions
about you know controversial or
sensitive issues
she really doesn't answer them she
responds that she wants to unify my
mission is to use sport as a force for
unity she seems very aware that there's
a risk to criticizing or be perceived as
criticizing the chinese government or
its its policies
this has helped keep goo's marketing
power strong but it's a double-edged
sword because if there's a misstep that
could put goo's sponsors at risk what
the brands are doing is sticking as
closely as possible to her sporting
abilities mark dreyer has been covering
sports in china for 15 years and wrote a
book about the industry he says one slip
up by goo could lead to enormous
financial losses
take for example a 2019 incident when
the general manager of the houston
rockets tweeted in support of
pro-democracy protests against china's
government on the streets of hong kong
this post was quickly deleted but it
created a ferocious backlash on chinese
social media and prompted a one-year ban
of nba games on chinese television the
nba said the losses from the tweet could
amount to nearly 400 million dollars
dryer says the best thing goo could do
is stick to her one message of unity to
both sides if anyone is seen to be
saying one thing to uh to to the west
and another thing to china
that generally uh irritates both sides
and and can get some people into trouble
baku has faced some criticism for her
lack of a political stance on issues i
do think that uh if she can if she can
keep winning competitions and stays on
the top of her game uh that's the
perfect way to to uh sort of uh shout
down her critics
but as a rising olympic star endorsing
some of the world's biggest brands
pleasing her critic seems to be the last
thing on her mind i'm not trying to keep
anyone happy i'm an 18 year old girl out
here living my best life like i'm having
a great time